[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to Episode Number
96 of the Weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am
well, Francesc.
How are you doing?
Currently in the city
of Austin, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
You're in the city of
Austin, I'm in San Francisco,
and you're wearing a beautiful
ladies gender-neutral T-shirt.
I actually saw that on Twitter
and it's a beautiful T-shirt.
MARK MANDEL: I am
wearing my T-shirt.
It's my favorite ladies T-shirt.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I was going to ask
how many you have, but,
you know, that's up to you,
so I will not judge.
Anyway.
MARK MANDEL: Well the ladies--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's gender-neutral.
MARK MANDEL: So all my-- all my
T-shirts are ladies T-shirts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: True.
That's a very good point.
It's a very good T-shirt.
I really like it.
Anyway we'll have a picture
on the show-- no, maybe not.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Or just
follow me on Twitter.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So we-- today we're going to be
talking about something quite
cool that actually I
didn't know anything about.
It is Avere, and it's a hybrid
file system for the clouds--
with an "S" I'd say.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We have both Dave
and Scott joining us
on the show, one Googler
and one from Avere,
basically talking
about how you can
build hybrid file
systems that span
both on-prem and the cloud.
It's actually
really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very, very interesting episode.
And then after that, we'll
have a question of the week,
and the question of
the week is, OK, I've
heard that Google Cloud
Container Builder is cool,
how do I get started?
Like, is there some tutorial
that I could go through?
And the answer is actually yes
and we'll answer that later.
But before that, we have
our cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we have
a lot of them, actually.
I'm going to start with
the first one, which
is something really cool.
So we have a new region
in South America,
and it is in Sao Paulo.
So if you're in Brazil,
congratulations,
because now you have a very,
very close-to-you region.
And it is really
cool because it's
going to be a big thing to
celebrate in the Google Cloud
Summit in Sao Paolo,
which if I'm not mistaken,
is next month.
MARK MANDEL: Are you
going to be there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No,
I will not be there.
Probably not, because I have
other plans, other trips.
But according to this,
it's November 8th
and 9th, so if you
have not registered,
try to find it-- actually, we'll
have a link on the show notes
to the registration form.
But otherwise, just find
Google Cloud Summit Sao Paulo.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome The second
one is one of those things
that I just know for how long
people have been like, when
are you going to have this?
When are going to have this?
When you're going to have this?
So now we have IPv6 on
our global load balancing.
It is now GA.
You can go nuts with
all your IPv6 needs.
So global load balancer
is our load balancer
that spans the globe,
which is awesome.
So now you can do load balancing
for a HTTPS, SSL proxy,
TCP proxy, all the good things.
Pretty excited now that we
can finally do all that stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, because IPv4,
we're running out of IPv4
addresses this year, right?
Is it the same time as the year
of the Linux on the desktop?
Or is it a different year?
MARK MANDEL: Every year is
the year of the Linux desktop.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
And it's every year we're
running out of IPv4.
OK, and the next one is about
Cloud Natural Language API,
and it is pretty interesting
because it's basically
the one that allows you
to extract knowledge
from text basically--
I think it's a decent
way of putting it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
what it's doing now,
it's actually able to classify
the context of the text.
So if you are
looking for something
and you have the
word lobster, right?
Lobster, when you're talking
about lobster and potatoes,
that's probably cooking, but
if you talk about lobster,
it may be, I don't know,
rocks and stuff like that.
Maybe you're actually
talking about biology.
So this new feature,
what it allows you to do
is to extract that context
out of the information, which
is something very useful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really cool.
We've actually got
two articles we're
going to talk about
here, one of which
just sort of goes through
the new things here.
So it's got classifying content.
It also has more sentiment
analysis on entities,
so you can get some good ideas
about the idea of what sort
of tone people might be using.
But the second article actually
has example code in it,
so you can go through and
see like results from JSON
and how you can interact
directly with the API,
so we'll have both of those
linked the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really
like that the example
for the context detection is
something that I would not
be able to reply, because I
have no idea of American sports,
but it says, Rafael Montero
shines in Mets victory
over the Reds.
I have no idea what that means.
That's team sports, baseball.
MARK MANDEL: I
[LAUGHTER] --no idea.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it is good.
It's an API, and it's
more useful than myself,
which is always good.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
And so finally, last one--
Google Cloud Dataprep
is now in public beta,
so you may have seen the
announcement back in March
where we announced
it as a private beta.
But basically it is
a visual way that you
can look at data
stores and big datasets
so that you may need
to clean up or modify
or basically being able to look
at and do transformations on,
but doesn't necessarily
require a programmer interface.
So basically for
analysts, things
like that who want to be able
to do it directly through a UI.
It actually looks really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Isn't this what we saw as
a solution at some point
to show a really fancy way of
showing billing information?
I think it's based on
[INAUDIBLE] BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: I think you're
talking about Data Studio,
which is the visualization.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I keep
on mixing those two,
and I feel like maybe
we should have someone
from those teams
come explain that.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If you're a
project manager or an engineer
from Cloud Dataprep or Data
Studio, please come talk to us.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
We would love to
have you on the show.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So that was all of the
cool things of the week--
or actually, the cool
things of the week
that we had time to go over.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I
think it's time to go
and talk to our friends from--
actually, friends from Avere
and Google, Dave Elliot
and Scott Jeschonek.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds
good, lets go do that.
Today I am very excited to
have Dave Elliott, Developer
Advocate for Cloud
Platform at Google,
and as well as
Scott Jeschonek, who
is the Director of Cloud
Products at Avere Systems.
Thank you both for joining us,
how are you doing today, Scott?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Doing
great, thanks for having us.
MARK MANDEL: And how are
you doing today, Dave?
DAVE ELLIOT: Fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us today
to have a chat about
your systems, the stuff
that you build on top of GCP
and the products you have
and how they came about.
But before we get into that,
why don't you tell our listeners
a little bit about yourselves.
Dave, why don't you go first?
DAVE ELLIOT: Sure.
So I'm a Developer Advocate
here with the Cloud Platform.
Been with Google for
about four years.
My background is
storage and networking,
and I spend most of my time
now working with companies,
in particular enterprises that
are looking to adopt Cloud,
and in particular, looking
at adopting cloud and storage
solutions.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Scott, why don't you
tell us about yourself?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Hi.
So yeah, I've the Director of
Product Management at Avere,
specifically for our cloud
products and our software
roadmap.
I've got a varied
background in IT
as well as telecom software
products, and most recently
at Avere Systems with storage.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So now that we know
who you are, let's
talk a little bit about Avere.
What is Avere and
what do you do?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: So Avere's
around nine years old-- eight,
nine years old, and, you
know, when we originally
started the product
line and the company,
it was to address performance
and latency issues with network
attached storage.
So if you were--
let's say you were
creating a movie
and you wanted that
movie to be rendered
in a certain period of time and
you created a render farm, you
have, whatever, a thousand
servers sitting there, well,
those servers are going to beat
the crap out of your network
attached storage, it's
inevitable, especially back
then because flash
was still really
expensive and hard to really
come by for those solutions.
Over time, we evolved
our solution off
of our data center
product and started
adopting cloud technologies.
Specifically, if you wanted
to create, for example,
a render farm in
the cloud and you
wanted to orchestrate
that and run
that against some data that's
sitting wherever, Avere
provides the technology,
the caching technology,
data access file
technology for that.
But we also support
abstracting a POSIX file system
on top of Google Cloud Storage.
So if you have applications
that you want to run
and you want to put all
the data up in the cloud
but you really need
those POSIX bits
and you need to manage it as
you did before, Avere gives you
that continuity.
MARK MANDEL: So is this
just a cloud solution?
Is this something
you can run on-prem?
Like, where does this
thing actually sit?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Great question.
So it can be both.
We have customers today, very
large studios in Hollywood
that do a lot of rendering
and it's all on-premise.
But we have other
customers in that space who
have started to break up
their data center clusters
and are looking
at running in GCP.
A lot of the reason that
they want to do that is it's
far more flexible.
They don't have to own so much
hardware on-prem, especially--
like, a lot of these
guys have sort of
capped out as to
how much they really
want to put in a data
center, so having GCP,
especially being able to
take their existing workflows
and putting them up there
is a real advantage.
So we run both on-prem and
we ported our appliance
into GCE instances that can run
in GCE, adjacent to whatever
workload that you're running.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
It sounds like it's either
on-prem or on Google Cloud.
Is that the case?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: That's right.
Or both.
You can plug them into both.
We're like the Swiss army
knife of data access,
basically, when it comes
to that kind of thing.
DAVE ELLIOT: Yeah that's part
of the beauty of what they offer
and how they help our
customers approach
and sort of realize
hybrid cloud, right?
If you think of your
compute instances
in the cloud, your
compute instances on-prem,
your storage in the cloud--
say with GCS-- and your storage
on-prem, what Avere
helps companies do
is sort of move between those
four entities, those four types
of compute and storage.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We're saying that we
are able to have storage
that is distributed
in between the cloud
and on-premise,
does that mean that you
connect in through a VPN?
Does everything need to
be in the same network?
How does this work?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So if I were truly a
developer on our team,
I would say it depends.
And it depends on all
the variables, right?
So typical use case
is going to be,
we're going to
recommend that you're
using a gigabit per second
link over the network.
Because a lot of
our customer base,
they're not doing really
small-scale stuff,
they're doing some
pretty serious uploading
and processing of data,
so laws of physics,
you want to make
sure that data gets
there as quickly as you can.
VPN over the internet
is a little tricky
because we're then at the
mercy of whatever latencies
the internet provides.
One of the things that our
product really strives to do
is be a killer of latency
when it comes to workloads.
So for any 1,000
VMs in GCE, they
can't afford to have latency
bogging down the job.
And so we typically want to
have a link behind us that
is sufficient enough to get
as much data into our layer
as we can.
Oh, and you also
asked about network.
So like from a GCE
perspective, you're
going to run the Avere cluster,
and we only run cluster.
You're going to run
that in a subnetwork--
not a classic subnetwork,
but a regular subnetwork
in GCE with your compute nodes.
MARK MANDEL: And does Avere like
encrypt the traffic through?
Or how does-- what is the
security side of things here?
SCOTT JESCHONEK:
Well, so it's twofold.
One, if you're using us as a
data access layer with your NAS
back on-prem, so that's one
of the typical use cases,
is I may have a NetApp
or an Isilon environment
and I just need to get to
some subset of that data,
we're going to tell
you-- and we have
written this all up
in best practices--
that you're going
to want to secure
your link between your data
center and the Google network.
And it wouldn't matter
if you were just using us
or if you were using any
of the Google services
that require that
kind of interaction.
And we don't encrypt
that, we would
expect that to be encrypted.
But since we also can use
GCS as backing storage, which
is kind of an interesting
twist, we basically
treat GCS as block--
we become the NAS for that--
that's all SSL encrypted,
as well as the data
being encrypted at REST.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So here at the podcast, we are
firm believers in open source,
so I'd like to know--
is this open source?
Is there is something
that we can check out
the code and stuff?
SCOTT JESCHONEK:
Open source, being
a vendor, such a struggle.
So, you know, look, I'll
tell you what we did do.
With one of the things about our
products, since it's clustered,
you know, the core code itself
is proprietary, because it's
highly tuned for caching.
We do a lot of complex read
ahead and write behind.
I always kind of
liken it to like
putting rocks in a raging river
and trying to steer the data
or steer the water
in a certain ways.
It's very difficult
to do and you never
know what's going to
happen downstream,
so that's really
complicated stuff.
But to manage and
set up the cluster,
especially if you're
a developer and you're
looking to create like an
orchestration pipeline,
we created a Python library
that we've put up in GitHub,
we'll give you the URL
to it, it's no problem.
And as long as you are able
to access our image, which
as simple as reaching out
to Avere and asking us,
we can grant you evaluation
access to the code.
And this Python library,
you can pick your poison.
You can either import it
into your Python logic--
that's fine-- and create
clusters of our product
pointing at your network
attached storage back on-prem
as long as you have the
IP address of the export,
you don't even have to--
this can all be
done very easily.
And we also created
a wrapper Python
for that, so basically
with one line,
you can set up the entire
cluster, fully configured,
ready to go.
DAVE ELLIOT: I will say
from a Google perspective,
you have some options if you're
looking at file services.
You can use our
single node filer.
There's some
limitations-- actually,
a fair number of
limitations on that.
You could also--
we support cluster,
so if you truly are looking
for an open source solution,
some of the challenges
there are really
around configuration
management of large clusters.
Or you can use a
commercial partner.
Avere is our go-to partner
for these file services.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
We actually discussed
on Episode--
let me try to remember--
Episode 40-- that was
a very long time ago.
We interviewed Rodeo FX and
they were talking about how
they were using GlusterFS.
Would you say that
Avere is kind of like
more managed and all ready
to use version of GlusterFS?
What are the differences?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Oh yeah.
So I'm going to make
it a hypothetical,
even though what I'm saying is
directly related to a customer,
OK?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
SCOTT JESCHONEK: So we
now have a customer,
they're in the render space,
they build with Gluster.
The reason they did it, which is
a reason a lot of folks do it,
is--
well first of all, you
know, if you're a developer
and you're good at
what you do, you just
want to get what you
need and move on.
And that's one of the
advantages of open source,
it's like, go get Gluster code
and go run it and I'm done.
But it's never as simple as that
when you start to introduce it
into a complex environment like
a render environment, where
latency is an issue, long-term
maintenance is the issue,
you're getting chased by
angry artists and angry studio
people that want, you know,
the latest scene rendered now
and there's an issue
with Gluster open source
that you can't figure out.
So, you know, you have to take
ownership of a lot of stuff
there.
The question that
I always put back--
and this will sound sales-y for
the developers, I apologize,
I'm not in sales--
is, that your core business?
Is storage and performance of
storage your core business?
No, it's rendering movies.
So the faster you
can render a movie,
whether you're using commercial
products, open source,
or a combination of it, the
better off for the company.
So I would say where we're
different is first of all,
you can have a
cluster of our product
up and running in about eight,
nine minutes using that Python
code ready to go serving ops.
You can plug in storage from
on-prem, which with Gluster
you really kind
of can't do that.
You can have a mount
point, but you're
going to be at the mercy of
whatever the latencies are
of that link.
And then ultimately with
Gluster, you know, is it HA?
Are you going to have
redundant storage
and then your costs are going
to go up from what you think
is going to be a relatively
inexpensive solution.
Once you start trying to
scale it with 500, 600 VMs,
you're quickly going to find
that Gluster just can't keep up
and you're going to
need something-- either
you're going to have to
build on top of Gluster
your own custom environment,
which again puts you
in a different business, or you
look for a commercial provider.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So let's swing back around to
sort of developer experience
and how that works.
So I'm kind of curious as well.
So you say there's
a POSIX file system.
So does-- all right, so
there's two questions.
One, so this
essentially means that I
can interact with this once
it's all mounted and set up.
Basically like a
local file system
and then you'll handle
all the latency?
And the other question I'll
tack onto that is, does this
work in both directions?
Can I go from cloud to prem
and then prem to cloud?
Like, how does that work?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Absolutely.
So to answer your first
question, so from a developer
perspective, you know,
you have Google Cloud
Platform with a lot of
fantastic technologies,
like all the machine
learning and TensorFlow
and the micro services
capabilities, that's
all exciting and it's
sort of like you're
starting to think
about, how can I
develop with all these
new tools and what value
can I drive in the company
with these new tools?
And that's great.
And at your next cycle, that's
what you're building towards.
But then you have this whole
host of applications today--
and I'm going to exclude
database applications just
because if I were using
a relational database,
I'd go put it up in Google's
relational database product
and be done with it just
to make my life simpler--
but let's just think about
file-based applications
that you have.
So let's say their business,
you know, mission critical,
can't really tear them
down and reauthor them.
They're six, seven years old
and they've just been working,
do you really want
to break that?
Well, you know, why do that?
Just go run it up
in Google, run it
on some the VMs
or some containers
and we just present
a mount point.
So you just mount that export
and you're ready to go.
That's the easiest way to
look at it from a developer's
perspective is, do I want
to spend time rewriting
a lot of things that I
don't need to and therefore
delay my entry into cloud
because of all of that?
Or do I want to just slam
them up there into the cloud,
use the exports from
the Avere, and then I
can go work on these other
new and interesting things
while that stuff's just
doing what it used to do?
MARK MANDEL: And to the
second question, which
is can I go in both directions?
SCOTT JESCHONEK:
Thanks for reminding me
about the second question,
which I totally forgot about.
Yeah, so let's say you're
using our physical appliance.
What are the use cases
with our product?
Especially in life
sciences, so like all
the genetic
sequencing companies,
they're creating amazing amounts
of data-- petabytes of data,
they've got to put it somewhere.
And so they're all
looking at putting it up
into places like
Google Cloud Storage,
but the problem
that they all run
into, especially in
that particular space,
is all their pipeline
applications,
everything they use to do
alignment and variant analysis
and everything,
they're all file-based.
People are rewriting
some of them,
but it's the same problem again.
Is that my day job?
Do I have time to stop
people using the classic tool
to get this new tool
and then I have to spend
six months debugging it?
Or can I just put
the stuff up there?
And so Avere allows to put
it into Google Cloud Storage,
but we put it
there in a way that
allows you to see it as POSIX.
And when I say POSIX, it
means a directory structure,
the standard POSIX bits, and
we also do it in a sharded way
so that you don't have to worry
about multi-part gets and puts
or having to get the
entire file out of Google
and pay the egress charge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I don't know
if it's my jet lag
or it's just like
I've missed something,
but I'm curious about
where do you actually
store this information?
Is it stored in GCE instances?
Is it stored in Cloud
Storage and persistent disks?
Where does this information
actually live at the end?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: It
is not your jet lag.
It's a completely legitimate
question everybody asks us.
So one of the things
to think of us as--
and when people ask
us what we really do,
I say we basically
facilitate access to data
and we do it at a high
performance level, all right?
The data itself
resides on your NAS.
It resides in your GCS bucket.
The only data that
resides on Avere
is any data that
has been requested
by clients for the latest job.
So it's basically a cache.
We also leverage
local SSD technology
in Google, which, by the way,
I mean, Google's local SSD
facility is fantastic, we get
great performance out of it.
We also do support
the persistent SSDs,
but you get an upper
bound of throughput
on the persistent SSDs, so if
we want to max out performance,
we use local.
But again, it's
only transient data.
It goes away when you're done.
DAVE ELLIOT: Yeah.
I'll say, you know,
Avere Systems,
these are file system experts,
and the caching algorithms
that they've developed
over their seven years
are unbelievable.
Best of breed or best around.
So, you know, it's
a scenario of,
you know, because they've
got these fantastic caching
algorithms, it makes
latency and performance
just that much better.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So my next question
is, since Mark
was asking about the
directions of the mappings
and they either can basically
get like Google Cloud
Storage as POSIX
systems on my instance,
can I also map the same folders
into multiple instances?
Like, is--
MARK MANDEL: Like
multi-read, multi-write?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Is Avere a good way
of communicating
across many different machines?
Or is it more a place where
you basically just use it
to store stuff that is being
used by one single worker?
SCOTT JESCHONEK:
Ah, good question.
The sweet spot use
case if you think
about it is, I'm going
to run a render farm,
I'm going to run a POST
sequence in genomic analysis
to cure some disease.
I'm going to do a
Monte Carlo simulation
in financial services so
I squeeze more money out
of my fund.
Those are all things that
run thousands of machines,
and typically those machines
are going to come up
and they're going to
all read some sort
of common set of data, and that
is tailor-made for caching.
So our-- where we really shine
in terms of technology is
if you have an HPC cluster
or a compute environment
and you've got a lot of nodes
demanding data from some
storage that is simply not going
to be able to keep up with it,
we do support writing
the data out--
so you can do your render and
then write out your results--
and we cache those
rights as well
and that gives you performance
on that side of it.
From the sort of single
client access in a folder kind
to use case that you
mentioned, that's
really like the domain of
something like a single node.
I mean, it just
depends on how you're
going to use that
particular technology.
It's not that we can't support
a single client doing it,
it's just that we're really
built for the high performance
space.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just to
dig a little bit deeper,
let's imagine that
we have, as you
were saying, a lot of
workers that are actually
within the same piece of
data, and then somehow there's
another worker that dates that.
What you're saying
is that you're
going to manage the caching
validation across all
of the places where
that information might
have been cached and that will
be transparent to the user?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Yeah.
And just to be clear, that's
within one of our clusters.
So a cluster can be three
nodes and three-node cluster
can serve as, I don't know, 500
n1-highmem-4's or highmem-8's,
so it's not a small environment.
But you can run 20 nodes, 23
nodes, 24 nodes of our system,
and that is a tremendously
large scale operation
that you'd be running there--
65, 70,000 cores.
But every right gets
cached and every read
gets cached for all the clients.
And the writes are
always protected,
so if somebody writes
something and somebody else
wants to read it, they're
going to read the latest.
If somebody tries to write
on that write, then that--
that'll all be
tracked and modified
and updated accordingly.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I have no idea what the
answer to this question
is going to be, but I'm curious.
So we're big fans of
Kubernetes and it's
been a hot topic about
how to store our data
inside particularly
containers in Kubernetes.
Is there a plug-in
or basically a way
for using of your technology
to do like persistent volume
claims or basically
store lots of data
so you can do like HPC
workloads on Kubernetes?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Yeah.
I mean, so I looked into this.
I also looked into
Hadoop, right?
And if you're not--
just to diverge for one
second from Kubernetes,
if you're using
Hadoop and you're not
married to Hbase and other--
like hQuery as part of your
sort of tool chain and you'd
be able to use your Hadoop
job as a file-based job,
you can actually do something
I call a hybrid Hadoop, which
is basically run a
Hadoop cluster in GCE,
use Avere access layer
against your NetApp.
On Kubernetes, I mean,
I'm a little torn,
because in terms of Kubernetes,
if you have a tiny small data
slice and you're a very
sophisticated developer
and you're able to place
that little slice of data
just so in each container,
you know, that's really fine.
I mean, you can go
ahead and use that.
But if you want, you can
use Kubernetes containers
with an export, with an
NFS export mount point.
So there's no reason why
you couldn't bring up
lots of containers
pointing at an export
and consume the data from
that export just as you--
MARK MANDEL: So
that's actually--
you hit the lead there a little.
So you also not only
got your own sort
of maybe FUSE technology
or something like that,
but you expose it as something
like NFS or other standards,
sort of file mounting
solutions, so
that if you have
existing tools, it's
super easy to just get those
up and running with Avere.
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Yeah.
Actually, you just raised
a critical point too-- this
is not FUSE.
So FUSE is a little tricky,
because it's user space,
it's got an upper
bounded performance.
If you just need to do
some basic stuff with FUSE,
I'm never going to
argue against it,
but it's not really meant
for high performance
sophisticated workloads.
It is-- you know,
the stuff we wrote
is grounded in very,
very fundamental code
that I, you know, unless we all
mutually have signed some NDA,
I can't really say what it is.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it sounded
like you had like an NFS mount.
Basically standard file
sharing type protocols
seem to be supported by Avere.
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Yeah.
So the front end of our product
basically presents NFS or CIFS.
And if you're using GCS object
as the backing storage for it,
it can actually support
multi-protocol out the front.
And it integrates with Active
Directory and everything else.
DAVE ELLIOT: So yeah,
Mark maybe we did bury
the lead a little bit on there.
Really, the two use cases we
really talk about with Avere,
one is this killer of
latency, because they've got
the great caching algorithms.
But the second is really that
translation layer, right?
For folks who want to use
those file-based services.
You know, who rely on NFS
or SMB to be able to begin
to move to our cloud.
SCOTT JESCHONEK: And just as
a side note, some small render
farms and studios,
their workflows
are based on SMB
CIFS, and so that--
we give them that luxury
of using that as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm curious a
little bit about
whether you can talk about
some of your customers
or cool use cases
that you've seen.
What kind of use cases?
We mentioned rendering.
What other things you've seen
that were powered by Avere?
SCOTT JESCHONEK: Sure.
So taking it along the same line
as anybody with a lot of need
to read a lot of common
data at a low latency,
we have a lot of
interesting use cases in--
I always say like Hollywood,
health, and hedge funds.
For some reason, those are
really sweet spots for us.
But we also work in
the oil and gas space,
so you've got a lot of
geologic analysis surveys
that are very read intensive.
You'll hear me emphasize read,
but just so that I'm clear,
we also have ingest use cases.
So for example, somebody I
cannot possibly name nor ever
will name somewhere in the
eastern part of this country
takes a lot of pictures, and
those pictures are being stored
in very deep storage.
And that ingest has to happen
at a certain high rate--
and we're talking about larger
files here so its clear.
And so, you know, especially
on our physical product,
we do a lot of write caching
and we have NVRAM cards
built into our hardware.
So were able to more quickly
ingest and acknowledge those
writes quickly.
And that's another important
point from a developer's
perspective-- if you
have a pipeline that
depends on receiving an ACK
from the protocol level,
Avere does the ACK
immediately after receiving
the write and cashes that
write across partners.
So let's see-- video ingest,
transcoding of video,
rendering farms, bio
informatics, name it.
I mean, pharmaceutical,
biological analysis, those
are all places that we'd like.
And we also sell to colleges.
DAVE ELLIOT: Right.
And the combination of being
able to leverage things
like on the compute side,
preemptible VMs, the cost
of spinning up
thousands of cores
and using them for
rendering or for hedge fund
trading or things like
that, you know, simulations,
it really is a game changer.
That really is I would say
probably the single biggest
killer use case.
Is that the latency
killer and enabling GCE
compute instances that are
wildly scalable, highly
available, and super,
super low cost.
That's where it becomes, you
know, super, super interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're kind of
running out of time,
but I have one last
question, which is,
what's the best
way to get started?
DAVE ELLIOT:
www.AvereSystems.com.
You can always reach out to
me and my contact information
is going to be posted and I can
put you in touch with-- yeah.
[LAUGHS] And I can put you in
touch with the right folks,
but it's really not
that difficult to get
started with the cluster.
And you can go out
to GitHub today
and get the Python library and
have a look at what we're doing
and what we base it on,
and that's the easiest way.
MARK MANDEL: And
is there anything
we haven't managed to cover?
You want to plug any
events or any special stuff
that you think our listeners
should know about Avere?
SCOTT JESCHONEK:
You know, probably
the next place that
we're going to be
is at the Google Summit on
September 27th in Chicago.
I will actually be
taking on booth duty,
so feel free to
stop by the booth
and we can certainly talk.
DAVE ELLIOT: And I'll just add
that Avere Systems actually
was the GCP Technology Partner
of the Year a couple of years
ago.
And we have ongoing
engineering alignment,
so you'll see better
and better and better
solutions with the two
of us as we go forward.
SCOTT JESCHONEK: That was
your wink and nudge, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Awesome Well, thank you
so much to both Dave and Scott
for taking the time today
to talk about Avere and
all the cool things people
are building with it.
SCOTT JESCHONEK:
Thank you, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
SCOTT JESCHONEK:
Thanks, everyone.
DAVE ELLIOT: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks so much
again to both Dave and Scott
for such an
interesting interview.
I hope it was fair for me
to ask about GlusterFX,
but I feel like it is really
interesting that there's
so many different options
to provide file systems that
are over the cloud plus
your own computers,
and it's important to be
able to make the difference
and, you know, love the answer.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, super, super
interesting stuff.
Same thing again, like, being
able to scale both your compute
and your storage across
on-prem and cloud I think
is very impressive
and also highly useful
for a bunch of workloads.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And I'm going to do a
shameless plug for ourselves
and say that if you want
to learn a little bit more
about similar use cases,
we interviewed RodeoFX.
She's a visual effects studio
that does really fancy things.
Among other things, they do
things for "Game of Thrones"
and "Deadpool" and stuff.
And they talk a
little bit about how
they use the cloud
plus their premise,
and they do use GlusterFX,
they do not use Avere,
but it is still a very
interesting use case,
so if you want to
check that out,
it was episode 40, a long
time ago-- that was in 2016.
Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely
check that out, that
was a great episode.
So why don't we get stuck
into our question of the week.
You set things up nicely, but
I know you have good answers.
So we were talking
about Container Builder.
Basically I want
to build some stuff
in the cloud using
Container Builder,
but I don't know
anything about it.
Like, where do I get started?
What can I do to learn
more about this thing?
It seems really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So the question was really cool
because the question actually
comes from someone
yesterday at the Go
Meetup that took place
in the Docker office
here in San Francisco.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And they
were talking about the newest
features of Docker.
And one of the cool things
that are coming but still
not in the stable release
is multistage builders.
And multistage builders are
super cool because they allow
you to basically do
the typical things we
do with a makefile, which is
you use a container with all
of your compilers and
all the developing tools,
and then out of that, you
generate a binary that then you
put in a different container.
And normally, we'll use
it to double the makefile.
At least I'm sure
that you, Mark--
MARK MANDEL: --I'm going to do
this in a makefile, yes, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For sure.
So now you can do that
with just one Docker file,
which is very useful.
And they asked me, so
how do you use this?
Like, do you upgrade
to the latest version?
And my answer was
like, actually no.
Actually you can
use this directly
on Container Builder, which
is super cool, because first
of all, you don't
make your machine work
too much because
the building process
itself will happen in
the cloud, but also you
get the newest
features of Docker
before they're
actually on stable,
because they basically pick
the best features in order
to have them there so you
can experiment with them,
which is really cool.
So the question after
that was, OK, cool--
how do I use this, right?
How do they get started?
And of course, the first
answer is, read the docs,
read the manual.
And we have a link to the
docs, but if I not mistaken,
is cloud.google.com/container
builder.
But anyway, we'll have a
link in the show notes.
The second thing
that you can do--
and it's the second shameless
plug of the episode--
is that we actually did an
episode with Christopher Sanson
and David Bendory which
are product manager
and one of the software
engineers in the Container
Builder team, where they told
us everything about Container
Builder.
And that was on Episode 79.
Now the thing I didn't know that
I discovered because someone
sent it to me via Twitter,
was that our dear friend
and coworker Carter Morgan
has this series on YouTube
on Container Builder.
And there's two videos already
and they're really good.
The first one is
basically an intro
to Container Builder plus
how to do cloud rolling
updates directly from Container
Builder, which is super useful.
And the second one is on how
to use not multistage builds,
but multistep builds, which
is not exactly the same thing.
Yeah, it's not exactly
the same thing,
it's basically
more like when you
want to go vet and go test
and then go build and then
send that to a container and
then that container should be
deployed somewhere else, right?
Those are multiple steps that
are not necessarily related
to Docker.
Multistage build is
inside of a Docker file.
So not completely the
same, but very related.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Now I really-- I love
Container Builder.
For a long time I was
kind of confused about it.
I thought it was a thing
to build containers,
but then I realized it
is actually a thing that
builds things with containers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Which is it
flipping mental thought, yet--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Slightly
ambiguous naming?
Yes,
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
great product nonetheless.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, well
before we wrap up,
Francesc, you going anywhere?
Doing anything interesting?
Is there a JustForFunc
we should know about?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by
the time this comes out,
there will be a JustForFunc
that will come out on the 25th.
And also, on that day I
will be flying to Chicago,
because on the 27th I will
be speaking at Cloud Summit
Chicago and I'll be
presenting about TensorFlow.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: All
right, so about that.
Yeah, and after that, as
I said before, there's
going to be a bunch of events,
I'll be at Velocity London,
I'll be at Cloud
Summit in Paris,
and I'll be in [INAUDIBLE]
all of that the same day,
basically.
I'll be there from basically
October 17 to the 20.
There's going to
be four days where
I'm going to be speaking every
single day in a different city.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Fun.
Yep.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: When this
episode comes out,
I will be actually
on a plane going
to St. Louis for Strange Loop.
So I'll be hanging out there.
If anyone else is also
going, wants to say hi,
please come up and say hello.
Then in October, I will also
be going over to Australia--
and as you've just got back.
I will be speaking
at DevFest Melbourne,
at GCAP Asia Pacific,
I'll be hanging out at PAX,
I'll be hanging out at Unite.
I do have some days free, so
if any people who are listening
and from Melbourne and they
want to get together and talk
about cloud or games
or games in cloud
or any of that sort
of stuff, please
feel free to reach
out, ping me, I
would be more than happy to hang
out with you, have a coffee.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: [INAUDIBLE]
Melbourne things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I know that Google Developer
Group Cloud in Melbourne
will be happy to have you.
But I will let them find you.
I think it's been a while
that we have not done this,
so why don't we remind
our dear listeners how
to get in touch with
us so they can send us
cool things of the week or
questions of the week or just
random rants or say that they
love us and were amazing--
also we accept that
kind of critique.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, sounds good.
You can ask the questions,
I'll fill in with--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, yeah,
because I-- yeah, the Slack I
will never get it ever.
So let's start with Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: It's @GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
are also on Google+.
MARK MANDEL: At +GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
do have a web page.
MARK MANDEL: It's
GCPPodcast.com.
Or cloud.google.com/podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we also have an email.
MARK MANDEL:
Hello@GCPPodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We are on Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: /r/gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And last but
not least, we're on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: At the #podcast
channel in bit.ly/gcp-slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And someone
mentioned at some point,
we are the only podcast
that doesn't say, please
rate us on iTunes or
subscribe or whatever,
so please do that too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, please
subscribe, that would be good.
Yeah, I don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Please
subscribe and leave
like good reviews and stuff.
Apparently it's important
so please do it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Please, like,
subscribe and stuff.
I don't know, I feel kind
of weird saying that.
But anyway, that sounds
like it's going to be great.
So we love all of you.
Please do the nice thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There you go.
MARK MANDEL: All right, friends.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you once
again for another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you, Mark, and thank
you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]